aujourd'hui on se merci d'être heures
direct avec avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors le texte controversé
maintenant définitivement adopté
concrètement comment cela va se passer
pour les salariés bah justement en plein
temps concrètement sur le terrain
beaucoup de choses sont déjà en train de
se préparer alors que la loi n'est pas
qu'on est sorti mais n'est pas encore
applicable et donc du coup effectivement
nos salariés ceux qui sont pas vaccinés
sont d'allah dalenc dans l'angoissé
l'inquiétude et n'arrête pas de nous
téléphoner pour pour savoir ce que ce
qu'on peut faire quoi mais effectivement
un c'est pas facile et nous avons
quelques soignant mais nous n'avons pas
beaucoup de soignants qui sont pas
vaccinés c'est ça le problème explique
l'inquiétude à cause notamment de la
possibilité de licenciements en cas de
non respect du bassin sanitaire on sait
qu'elle a été retirée alors dû tirer en
l'air
elle a été retirée suspension mais
effectivement un qui est habilité
justement à vérifier notre vaccination
fait ça je rappelle que quand même
normalement du domaine du secret médical
et que seule la médecine travail est
habilité à savoir qui on est vaccinés ou
pas et voilà donc du coup qui va qui va
contrôler quoi c'est toutes ces
questions que nous posons qui va
contrôler comment ça va se faire voilà
on est là face à des menaces de
sanctions
on peut dire ce que vous pensez que
cette mesure justement ces menaces
peuvent pousser le personnel réticents
qui n'est pas encore vaccinés à le faire
alors il est évident que nous risquons
de perdre des salariés oui bien sûr au
rendez compte qu'il ya un an nous étions
à claudie au balcon mais que sa tournée
nous sommes atypiques matiz est juste
parce que nous ne sommes même pas ce que
certains ne sont pas vaccinés voilà il
faut il aurait fallu d'abord cherché à
savoir à convaincre sans les contraindre
à peut-être à proposer dans certains
endroits plus de facilités pour la
vaccination ce qui n'a pas été le cas
tout le monde n'a pas joué le jeu et a
cherché à savoir vraiment pourquoi ils
n'étaient pas vaccinés plutôt que de les
contraindre avec des menaces
justement vous venez de dire que voilà
les soignants ont été en première ligne
pendant la crise du crédit le sont
toujours d'ailleurs et ce qu'ils
comprennent le risque qu ils le
comprennent mais enfin ils le
comprennent
ils ne comprennent ils savent que cite
cependant vaccinées dont ils vont
peut-être avoir des menaces de
licenciements mais il ne voit pas en
quoi ils peuvent mettre en danger
puisqu'ils ont la plupart du temps ils
prennent les mesures nécessaires pour
protéger quand même les patients qu'ils
avaient oublié que l'année dernière ils
étaient au front sans matériel cette
année nous avons du matériel donc on ne
peut pas dire qu'ils mettent plus en
danger la population qu'ils reçoivent
que d'autres secteurs
on n'est pas plus sans danger à
l'hôpital qu'ailleurs il n'y a pas eu
tant de clusters que scène à nos
hôpitaux un faux pas il faut tout
relativiser quand même vous êtes
secrétaire fédéral santé action sociale
de la cgt est ce que vous avez
l'impression que ces sanctions vont dans
le sens d'un recul des droits des
travailleurs mais oui parce que ce
vaccin il n'est pas autant quand on
comprendre par exemple d'un de shedden
employeurs ont fait qu'on a des vaccins
obligatoires et du coup on assume ce
fait là autant là ce vaccin on n'a pas
de recul il n'a pas reçu toutes les
autorisations il est pour l'instant à
l'esprit donc moi je trouve qu'on fait
on trouve qu'il ait fait plus compliqué
à
à contraindre est quelqu'un de le faire
un vaccin classique voilà et ensuite on
n'a pas cherché non plus avoir auprès
des récalcitrants entre guillemets si on
peut appeler ça des récalcitrants
le dosage d un petit corps par exemple
pour savoir si éventuellement il n'avait
pas déjà eu le cosy d'autres sachant
qu'on envoie toujours des salariés on a
et l'année dernière on l'a fait des
salariés positif asymptomatiques
travailler à ce moment là sans se poser
de questions le gouvernement qui
multiplie justement le contact auprès
des français jean castex ce qui était en
déplacement au lycée vers ans également
pour essayer justement donné de les
convaincre de dialoguer avec eux est ce
que c'est important justement qu'il ait
plus de communication autour de cette
vaccination
oui mais sans les stigmatiser parce que
ce qui a mis je pense en colère certains
salariés cette petite maddie actions que
nous avons eue il ya un mois et demi
deux mois là où des salariés d'un but
n'est pas d'en été accusé d'avoir mis 1
d'avoir été la cause de décès dans une
ehpad
voilà et ça c'est on peut pas on peut
pas juger des gens comme ça on ne sait
pas poser d'autres questions à notre
endroit d'un autre lieu
on a fait des des rassemblements depuis
le dernier de confinement il y avait
beaucoup moins de protection que ce que
nous prenons à nos hôpitaux
nous travaillons toujours à flux tendu
avec des délits toujours fermé chose que
nous avons demandé depuis demandant
depuis 3 4 ans monsieur vérone de
rouvrir des lits de d'embauché
massivement ce qui n'est pas encore le
cas
donc on peut pas stigmatiser notre
personnel juste sur le fait que quelques
uns seraient pas vaccinés quoi mon père
ce mandat mon hôpital on est vaccinés à
plus de 80%
donc c'est très peu ce qui reste à
vacciner et c'est un leitmotiv ans je
pense qu'on va les combats les
convaincre merci plus dans les
accompagnant merci beaucoup en tout cas
cv pense d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes s'avère
fédéral santé actions cela mais de là